oh I'm all right
can touch from the Department of
Anthropology the council on our key
logical studies and Peabody Museum at
Yale University and I'm chairing the
session the second session on the
illicit traffic in antiquities
interdiction and suppression and we'll
begin with my colleague from Molly the
national director of cultural heritage
from Molly lisanna Cisse & lisana has
asked me to do a simultaneous
interpretation for a good morning
everybody i ask i ask is for my hopeless
english and ask my friend to to help me
to translate because i have a lot of 22
to communicate but in English is too
hard for me sorry for this don't rush me
repeat knapa see the money see Africa
the West smullins in west africa from
west MP continent allah curbed a freak
the best a simple pattern one it's a
landlocked country but a country of
great heritage the population the PDCA
varde millinery yeah I'm prasant Lee
grooves ethnic molly was well known for
having many ethnic groups that that one
whole cup well we got on well together
sakina trail manga dune a precise
quadrillion pulmonary and because of
that cultural mix is very very rich
cultural heritage a la prova concern a
eurasian particular que bonito move to
he will start off with a an area that's
known perhaps to you the area of
Timbuktu a quien sita emblematic
inshallah did as Croesus la luz de parte
1 module temperature was a scribed on
the
heritage list a kuda trauma ski because
of three very important historical
mosques the Missoula qet d3 and 16 Sufi
say musalia that were destroyed voila
danke um DeMille doozy I said grab Chris
in 2012 there was a could determine late
there lucrazon partly rupiah distant to
give me a coup d'etat in the military
coup d'etat in the capital at the same
time as invasion uncle Lukie pasando
tutelary Sean or kayla party important
so two-thirds of the northern part of
molly was was overtaken by a shoelace
lake at cts chrysalis de Patri manuel
que vous VA tombouctou jenny by jaga
rapido y le tombeau de zaskia lik dat
social at least department Morgan so the
poor areas that were described on the
world heritage list were affected by
this action don't set ratio looper to my
night t-series mando mushy LG and there
was serious damage in each of the places
voila possum all Department material may
see to limit any Lucy not just the
material heritage but a very very rich
customary heritage of these areas voila
transitions mozu legs ontd tree reskin
directo [ __ ] Katie S&P t'as vu ah Lord
latrans idiom CC on the committee deep
at Memorial and we see 13 of the 16
mosaic words were reserved our sister
Ella destruction disease in missoula a
be surplus lay totally pratik the
material ID entered it and just as
importantly these were the Centers for
customary rituals and and and practices
that were absolutely forbidden an
imposing a while off our maple st to lay
money screams a Yankee chicken stew teen
important one president port exceptional
on Africa Sudha Sarah there was
repression of women and also probably
known to all you destruction of many but
not all of the Islamic manuscripts and
we brew late ap trafficky many were were
burned some were were trapped Julia
constant T c-mella population resisted
but there was local resistance and next
filter only managed to Berlin and one of
the world la mejor para TI text field
radio on Tracy intelligent public
municipal compound a resilience one of
the massively and optimistic issues is
the vast majority of those men you must
be created out of the timbuk2 and sent
to the CAF is a decomposing avec li Xue
coupons and there is overall resistance
to the demands of a la mode ET I'm for
mobilization 02 department a militia
force a lisa lucas andouille celui see
the piece MP textbook on de mildews
because of the publicity of what had
gone on there's been international
outpouring of support for Molly la por
la primera Fallanassi masini on demand a
ohh forces army international do pro tem
pat two months ET la primera flash prop
and and also the under the aegis really
showed us a sauce there to the
international armed forces coming into
Mali to take special care for the
website and amil traces foolish it de
lunes kokia for me and on monday for
Allah adopt em planned action lelu
government do Molly Adina school and the
channel by unesco an overall plan for
recovering the heritage and for this
which i decree as a weather with money
to help ya lol epic my own country be a
step exhaustive my sis on Selma CP
contributor reconstruction demo zulay a
poo suit Emile la rehabilitation demands
credos SPD patamon so this is a partial
list of the major downer sources i refer
don't do
favorite demille cut off as you add Emma
cast too late res mazzoli please go to
Mussolini some pasilla leesa itt country
so largely because of local efforts most
of the mausoleum have been reconstructed
using local salad on Cindy Mastry
participative iveco limassol okula
corporation damusaun to move to ya
antianna organized a really silly travel
the Constitution the traditional masons
of timber to who work in the very
characteristic mud mud brick have been a
major part of our victory generality a
tumble to don t know jerry cismoski a
decimal ceremonies of inauguration demos
aleppo yah doses paquete res important
complete a new console yeah the problem
don't own palpable KU SI la pluie PA de
sitter kulusuk continuing and
accelerating because of this shepherd of
course and not surprisingly is increase
of pillaging a gorgeous lady
presentations an apple pie see me and
feta phenomen the traffic the PSD city
cebu axon tree and the trafficking in
mulund heritage has really established
molly was one of the few countries in
the world that had basically stopped the
entire trafficking in art archaeological
sites before jenna dewan years ago near
your include islas gentleman day traffic
go sunny ago at the site of Jenny Jenny
Joe there had not been any pelagic since
nineteen nineteen ninety-five until this
happened and a very very important site
down river ouse on a is now devastating
mother is massive sue sue sue PhD seat
montecito geologic echoes doula chris de
tourisme and much of the pillaging is
that directly dependent upon the crisis
of tourism in other words the economy is
no longer getting that tourist dollars
and so local population has to depend on
said on the site a civilian pull my leg
Alma could do
Lynn security do a lager a symmetrical
ASAP anti-terrorist okie non pas prefer
yeah in a Secretary's residual down to
Sri Lanka so if the insecurity and
assassination still continuum SI loogu
dreamer et si vous remercie he's
thanking you for your attention